one of the biggest stories from this
week just the other day Ron DeSantis
signed two bills expanding the what the
media likes to call the don't say gay
bill which is the actually the parental
rights and education Bill and he also
banned what the left refers to as gender
affirming surgeries for minors or to be
factual I know I know a lot of people
get offended by facts they really do
they're very mad at me about it um child
sex change interventions surgery and
medication those are banned in Florida
and in response we're seeing a whole
bunch of lefties freaking out and of
course lying about what's actually going
on
another really big story that's been
going around for a while that we'll get
into is a teacher Who provided
instruction to middle schoolers their
kids who are like 9 to 12 years old and
let's just say adult activities and how
to secretly meet up with adults for
adult activities and of course NBC News
is lying about this trying to for some
reason cover it up so we'll talk about
that plus we got that that a woman the
nurse they called her a Karen said she
was trying to steal a bike from some
young black man but then it was proven
that she was actually being robbed by
them her lawyers saying they plan to sue
the media for defamation so we'll talk
about that in a bunch of other stories
before we get started my friends head
over to castbrew.com pick up some cast
Brew Coffee you'll like coffee coffee's
great support the show by joining the
cast Brew Coffee Club you'll get three
different bags every single month or you
can just come down here and buy
whichever blend you like I think we're
currently sold out of some of the rise
of Roberto Jr because y'all are buying
too much but uh more will be in stock
soon plus we've got K-Cups coming the
coffee shop is currently being built
casper.com support our work and we're
gonna be building physical locations for
people to hang out very excited about
this and head over to timcast.com join
us click that join us button become a
member support our work directly and
check out the members only shows from
this week because we had uh the the
episode yesterday
with Colby Covington
you probably want to see it because I
kind of just went off on this on this
rant about uh the the current drama
surrounding me one of our guests
canceled on us for the culture War
podcast so that wasn't live and it was
because I made fact statements seriously
I wasn't insulting anybody I said like
hey here's a statement about a thing and
they're like how dare you and then
cancel this not surprised not surprised
so we'll talk about that and how much
more smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us today to talk about
this and a whole lot more is Kingsley
Cortez hey guys thanks for having me my
name is Kingsley Cortez I'm a trump
campaign Alum I currently do digital
media at the center for newing America
in Washington DC and I'm also National
Committee woman for the DC young
Republicans so please follow me at
Kingsley Cortez on all the platforms I'm
on you know getter truth Twitter the
whole shebang right on thanks for
hanging out we got Phil Labonte hello
everyone I am Phil Labonte the lead
singer for all the remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
here with hello guys I am pradasivik I
am the host of Pop Culture Christ this
is right here on youtube.com we had a
great episode go up today with Gothic so
after this episode tonight you should go
and check that one out because it was a
lot of fun
and I am surge.com filling in for Kellen
PDL he is off Chasing Rainbows or
something I don't know what he's doing
but uh it'll be a good show so let's get
started all right let's jump into this
first story The outrage following Ron
desantis's ban on sex change surgery for
kids AP news reports parents of
transgender kids seek to block
desantis's ban on gender affirming care
for minors the first thing I want to say
about this is It's always language they
never tell you the truth this is what
got me and got me in trouble apparently
with one of our guests who's going to
come on the culture War podcast and then
did not is that
I'm not here to play games on the left
or the right but that means you're
basically going to be aligned with the
right what I mean by that is
we've got an editorial team over at uh
timcast.com we write news and uh one of
the Articles we were writing something
came up having to do with pro-choice and
pro-life and I was reading this and I
got kind of frustrated because there was
some quote from some activist and I said
I'm confused as to what they're trying
to say uh so I said I don't think we
should say pro-choice or pro-life those
are political terms if they're
protesting to ban abortion we should say
protesting in a in opposition to
abortion or protesting in support of
abortion so we can just say anti or
pro-abortion and everybody agreed like
that that's a fair point remove the
political terminology from it be direct
that triggers the left they get very
very angry so in this instance you can
see right there in the headline gender
affirming care for minors that is a
leftist term that is an ideological term
to support their idea why is the AP
doing that so somebody at the AP said in
our style guide we are going to just use
the language of left-wing activists
here's what we say the right would call
it mutilation okay I don't I don't call
it that and and many conservatives are
like no that's what look I'm saying it
is a child sex change surgery and
medical intervention that's just a fact
statement that pisses the left off to no
end if you don't use their language
you're like that's it they come after
you whereas the right will just go okay
I guess the left is a the left has a
very significant authoritarian streak in
them right now in the U.S and in the
west you have to think like they think
if you talk like that's where the whole
gender uh gender you know using
someone's pronouns comes from like you
have to think of a trans Woman as a
woman trans women are women not trans
women are trans women
um they make a demand on your cognitive
Liberty this is as authoritarian as it
gets they're demanding that you think
like them and it bothers me that
liberals actual liberals in the U.S
are bad liberals and they don't see that
this is not authoritarian so we got this
tweet from Chris Hayes I love this one
he says the law dissent to sign in
Florida Banning care for Trans kids is
Despicable and a frontal assault on the
vaunted parental rights he and his
idological cohort have been screaming
about for years in Florida you no longer
get to make Health Care decisions for
your own child Ron DeSantis makes them
it doesn't matter what you think is best
for your kids Ron tells you this is the
weirdest thing but I I feel like as long
as you read the stories you can see
through the thin veneer the lies what is
he talking about you can't make Health
Care decisions for your kids no there's
there's a there's a medical uh the chief
medical officer or whatever they have
for the the Surgeon General in Florida
who makes these medical decisions on
what doctors you know basically
overseeing how the health system is
working you've got low law the
legislature Ron DeSantis signed what the
state legislature presented to him they
are they they're playing a political
game probably because 2024 but it's all
just so crazy how they lie about all
this stuff there is no contradiction in
saying a parent has a right to decide
what a child learns and a parent does
not have a right to determine if their
child should be sterilized or not like
at a certain point the state intervenes
to protect children under Chris Hayes's
argument he thinks you should be allowed
to mercilessly beat your own children
well let's show you to what you think is
best for them right he's Pro snake
handling
like like that's the thing the the state
should not step in and prevent snake
handling your CH you are chopping off
the genitals of children if children are
gender dysphoric you wait until after
puberty because gender dysphoria tends
to go away the idea that Chris Hayes is
saying is that Pete like the state
should not step in and say you can't
starve your you can't starve your
children the state should not step in
and say you must provide medical care to
your children like it's stepping in and
saying that it's okay for for the state
to or for parents to literally cut their
children allow their children to cut
their bodies up everyone knows that
tattoo like forever tattoos have been
off limits for anyone under 18 and there
was never a stink about it and now
because it's not oh God just the LGBT
Lobby and the ideology that comes along
with with trans with the LGBT
perspective
out it's like it's all about trying to
to shove the the idea down people's
throats I was gonna say it's not just
surgery it's the medication too it's the
it's the chemical uh puberty blockers
and uh and crosstex hormones which also
cause sterilization to the point where
uh even these high profile websites that
are advising on what they call gender
affirming care say you have to preserve
your reproductive material as these
these treat these treatments they call
it will tend to remove your ability to
reproduce I think too just people like
Chris Hayes they aren't used to seeing
Republicans wield power and fight back
especially on cultural issues because I
mean the GOP in my lifetime has
delivered you know tax cuts and endless
Wars and that's about it so I think you
know for the first time to see
conservatives wading into the cultural
issues and pushing back and fighting
this totally nut stuff is really
important and I think it's it shocks the
left because they're not used to it but
we need to do more of it because if you
don't have a culture you don't have a
country it's because when they say boo
when they call you racist or sexist or
homophobic then they get everyone on the
right to immediately cave to whatever
demands they have because they
understand that they do wield the power
of most of the journalists and all of
the all of that complex in this country
so if you have the power of 10 000
journalists who can use a bunch of
buzzwords and names to call you you
wield a lot of power to stop people from
proposing bills that they want to
propose from speaking out on social
media in the ways they want to and the
media does the same thing when they use
these terms like gender affirming care
which are to the uninitiated will read
it and aren't going to look into it any
further and all they're going to get
from that is evil right-wing guy does
evil right-wing thing because they're
bad and I think for the average person
who doesn't read the whole article who
only reads paragraph one who doesn't
look into what the actual meaning of
these terms are that wields a lot of
power because people don't look any
deeper I'm torn you know I am on the one
hand I'm concerned concerned about these
children and whether or not these
treatments actually are the right thing
to do because the science shows
desistance rates are very very high we
went over this with Lance from the serfs
around uh reaching up to 98 or something
like that so most kids go through
puberty and then they just stop
experiencing this and we've already seen
in Europe they've been abandoning these
procedures on the other hand
I think if Chris Hayes wants to
sterilize his children we shouldn't stop
him and I'm and you know it's funny
because I'm half kidding that the issue
here is I'm not a conservative Chris
Hayes comes out and says his children he
has the right to bring them to a doctor
and remove their ability to reproduce
and I'm kind of like well I suppose the
challenge is do these children have
rights to not have their lives
irreparably harmed by the actions of
their parents answers yes of course just
because a doctor tells you to do it
doesn't mean it's the right thing to do
but these people are voting to to
terminate the lives of their children
and take away their and their children's
ability to reproduce and I'm kind of
like
we're we're not in a position to assert
uh absolute authority over them to stop
them from doing it there has to be a
vote on it in Florida the vote has been
you can't do it Chris Isis is losing his
mind but if this guy then moves to a
state that allows it like California
it's like okay well you know the worst
case scenario in the end of all this is
the future is conservative
conservatives have a bunch of kids
liberals sterilize their kids the the it
it just seems like it doesn't matter in
the grand scale it matters to the
individual it matters to the rights it
matters what we think people should be
allowed to do to kids because those kids
are going to grow up they're going to be
very angry we've already seen it many
detransitioners but then I'm thinking
about
holistically the whole the whole world
and where we're going this is a small
blip in the history of the United States
that I think will cease to exist
relatively shortly I mean I definitely
agree with you that they're almost you
know self-selecting out of reproducing
and you know yeah and for us on the
right I mean that means more votes for
us right but also does it mean more
violence for us you look at people like
the Nashville shooter or the individual
who killed that woman in Arizona so
there is you know I think having
mentally ill people running around your
Society is not conducive to a society
that is safe and allows for you know
Community flourishing this is a big
challenge across the board though like
we see in San Francisco we want to help
people who are suffering like this this
is this is one of the challenges humans
face balancing helping people with
making sure that the crazy people who
are unwell aren't dragging the whole
system down you know they say when
you're asking on a plane you got to put
the mask on the person you got to put
your own mask on before putting on the
mask of the person next to you so how
can we as United States keep doing the
opposite sacrament sufficing our cities
and our economies for people who are not
contributing it's just breaking the
system then eventually we're going to be
left with empty cities and Barren
streets and no farms and no food and
people are going to wonder how it
happened
the there's I I don't know I it's it's
just so tiring to hear people like you
said lie like hearing Chris Chris Hayes
portraying things the way that he does
it's just it's exhausting and and
extremely frustrating because there's
there's people that have lives and they
go about their day and they don't have
the time to shove their face in Twitter
or read a bunch of queer Theory books or
you know it's and that's one of the
things that the left really relies on is
people living their lives and going
about their day and not knowing what
they're talking about every like we talk
on this show all the time about the fact
that there are that the the left has one
dictionary or that we use the the same
uh same lexicon but a different
dictionary their meanings of words
change and stuff that's intentional your
average person doesn't know that your
average person doesn't understand that
so when the left starts throwing around
jarging at them they feel like they're
like I don't know what any of this this
means they're like ah just stop you know
whatever you say and it's such a
manipulate it's so manipulative and it's
frustrating to see so many people
constantly battering you with a message
and that that is is completely
fabricated I was talking to someone
recently when we were discussing the
idea that when you watch the news
depending on where you get your news
from you're living in a completely
different reality from the person next
to you if they get their news from a
different source and the language does a
lot of that in the same way you could be
having a conversation you but you might
both know the word but you have your own
definitions for what that word means so
you end up with a completely different
conversation and you never actually get
to any type of understanding because you
can't get past the dialogue that's
spoken and I think that's also a problem
when we talk about you were talking
about whether you think that this is a
self-correcting problem that's why
they're so good at organizing and why
they're so good at recruiting Because
recruiting is how they grow because if
they're not having families if they're
not expanding through their own gene
pool they have to organize through
Community leadership they have to
organize through propaganda in the media
and they do that very very well and I
think in social media Tick Tock that is
how they influence the next generation
of people I don't think it will be as
easy as just something that cancels
itself out in a generation or two
because a lot of these people
conservatives included there was a thing
on Mother's Day where it said happy uh
Happy it was a Happy Mother's Day post
and it was a bunch of iPads
because kids are looking at their
parents are putting their a tablet in
front of them they're not watching what
they're looking at in the media and
that's right the kids younger and
younger are being influenced on websites
that are not protecting them uh yeah
what kid under the age of 13 was
wouldn't know to hit the I yes I am 13
Button on Tick Tock right so the kids I
don't think it's ever going to be as
simple as just it's going to be drown
out by the fact that they're not
reproducing it's something that you have
to culturally change whether that's
through Pro you know putting out your
own media that will be an alternative
source to them or the type of thing
where they need to do better about
making sure their kids aren't taking in
a bunch of stuff that they don't know
but then what do you do from there then
you go to the school system the school
system pushes on it too they really have
surrounded the culture in every way and
to me it sounds black filled it's like
it's I don't think it's that simple I'm
not suggesting that we just sit back and
do nothing and then by having kids no
I'm saying it's all it's all
interconnected the less they have kids
and the more the right says we're not
bringing our kids to your schools you
will get a natural tendencies towards a
culture being developed by the right
which we're seeing across the board with
comic books and and cartoons as well as
parallel economies Jeremy's chocolate
and razors we got Casper coffee uh
Jeremy has uh Jeremy from the quartering
has coffee brand coffee a bunch of
companies popping up competing with the
establishment that is falling apart I
look at all of these in the big picture
and I'm just like over a long enough
period of time the future seems obvious
right I just I just feel like for me at
this at this point I'm like
I'm gonna invest in one of these
companies because it seems inevitable
sure there's a bunch of variables who
knows what'll change but I don't see how
you reverse course and Salvage the left
you've got decaying media organizations
they're going out of business CNN's
ratings have dropped below Newsmax
BuzzFeed news is gone Vice is is in
bankruptcy now all of these companies
they're they're losing clicks they're
losing followers they're freaking out
they're fleeing Twitter their influence
is crumbling then they're sterilizing
and aborting their own children
conservatives are pulling their kids out
of these schools their influence is
going to be gone in 10 years then you
add them to the fact that they're not
having kids give it 20 or 30 years and
you're going to have two new generations
entering the cultural space who have not
been influenced by their by their media
because their media is ceasing to exist
Disney just announced they're going to
be moving a whole bunch of their
products over was it from from Hulu to
Disney plus yeah they're gonna bundle
everything so that you can get
everything but that means they're
they're also locking things up they also
got rid of a bunch of the like Willow
and the really bad stuff that came out
that they took like 50 or 60 things off
Disney plus because it's literally just
taking up server space and nobody's
watching any of it so but I just think
all of those things together other
predict a conservative future
I mean it's it makes sense that you know
the theory that you have I'm not so sure
not so confident I think that the the
left's very is has a subversive uh
agenda and and I think that that it's
more than just trying to get people to
you know or just the people not having
kids I do think that the left is going
to come after the exact yeah but but
they can try but they're but they're
they're diminishing I think though they
own all the institutions right like if
you're one of these parents who's pissed
off that you know gay porn is in your
kids Library you protest that at a
schoolbird meeting you're going to be
put on a no-fly list like the FBI is
going to knock on your door so I think
that the fear Tactics still exist
because the left controls almost every
institution in this country and
combating that getting people to be
willing to combat that to put their
livelihoods on the line it's a hard
thing to do I think sticks hexenhammer
like two years ago said you're better
off you know organizing in the local
departments run for your local school
boards run for local government you'll
make more of a difference there than
worrying about the presidential race
which is in a lot of ways for most
people it's a spectator sport like do
they see how much of those decisions do
they see on the daily we see it now with
inflation and things like that but in
general you're going to get a lot more
mileage and you're going to get a lot
more out of working at your local level
yeah I think the local stuff is is
extremely important to people because
you can have a whole lot more you know
effect on on your local politics you
know if you can if you might bump into
you know you're selecting and obviously
if you're in like New York City or if
you're in one of the major cities it's
going to be significantly less likely
that you'll bump into like your I don't
know whatever they've have Alderman's or
whatever I don't know but if you in a
smaller town Chicago is Alderman's right
yeah yeah so you know it's probably not
very likely that you will but you'll
you'll run into other people that are in
your community if you're active in your
community and that's the way to have the
most influence on your community is you
know School school school boards or or
you know any kind of Civic stuff that's
going on that needs to be taken care of
that's why they got rid of civics from
government from school programs a long
time ago that was that was very much
planned I agree with you I think so but
you know I the the legal and local
method is is I think the actual way to
to go so let's uh let's jump to the
story and uh make everybody angry you
may have seen the story but we're gonna
we're gonna bring it up here for this
Friday show this is from today.com she
offered a lgbtq minus themed book to her
children normally they put the plus but
there's like a dash there so I had to
say minus anyway they say she offered an
lgbtq themed book tour middle schoolers
parents filed a police report
Danielle Campo amore she writes the
story saying she'd been at Illinois's
Middle School teacher for 20 years so
Middle School is uh what is that eight
to twelve eight to thirteen uh middle
schools eight to twelve yeah the book in
question is a book called this book is
gay
the article from today doesn't tell you
what she actually did I am going to keep
the language family friendly for all of
you because you may have children
listening
this teacher provided instruction to
children
children ages presumably middle
schoolers so we're 8 to 13 on how to
meet adult men for gay sex
she provided them on instruction on how
to consume
the bodily materials of other adult men
yeah there's that language again that
then I'm trying they win this is the
language because I think I told them
exactly what it was I'm being academic
no I'm saying this is why the article
wins because the average person reads it
doesn't know that that's what that says
it's an lgbtq themed book exactly it's
like that Meme says like no matter how
much you hate journalists you don't hate
them enough like this this is the that
that's well hold on that's what they
were saying about the others I have a
question I have a question Danielle
capua Moore wrote this
why did she not include that this
teacher was providing this degree of
instruction to children
because they're trying to hide it from
parents but but why would you want to
hide it from parents why does Danielle
Campo Amore this writer for today
not want parents to know that this
teacher
was instructing their children
on how to arrange Anonymous adult
activity activities with adults sexual
activities why why is she trying to
obfuscate this I think because you know
depravity and perversion seeks more of
that more of the same thing okay you're
getting warmer but what is that what
does that mean you're saying that
Danielle Campo Amore is depraved and
perverted I mean clearly yeah
is it possible then that maybe Danielle
campomore shares certain predilections
for children that this teacher might
is she also gay well I don't know about
that that that's not Material I mean
that's how she would write it I suppose
right but we're talking about a
middle-aged teacher giving a book to
children that explains them how to eat
male fluids
or I shouldn't say I'll be very careful
provides instruction on the process of
because it does I want to be I'm being
fair it does tell them not to do it
yes it says it says it's not safe but it
does include
definitional breakdown of
how it occurs and also what it means to
consume feces
these things are being provided to
children but more importantly it
explains to them in detail how to use
applications to upload their images as
children this is illegal it's
instructing them on
making
images of themselves to share with
adults for anonymous encounters
I can only assume I think it's the only
fair assessment is possibly why someone
working for a media organization would
obfuscate this they too are attracted to
children
because anybody who any any sane adult
who doesn't want children being harmed
this way is not going to cover up for
another pedophile or if they're
ideologically possessed they would yeah
I mean I I don't I mean I don't know
you're saying that perhaps Danielle
Campo more is not a pedophile herself
but that she wants to protect pedophiles
yes 100 I am absolutely saying that with
I full-throated I am saying that
actually I I would agree with that
because maybe it's it's viewed as like
you had that big movement I can say big
movement you had that that movement
among pedophiles lgbtp where they're
trying to get their get the P added to
their absolutely it didn't work but it
would make sense with that Ted Talk
where that woman tried saying it's like
she tried claiming it was normal you
have journalists who are like yes I
agree with you I will protect you people
that are familiar with queer Theory uh I
think Gail Rubin is one of the original
idea writers for queer Theory uh Mario
was a uh an Italian guy that was writing
in queer Theory
Foucault who's a postmodern leftist all
of these people that dip into queer
Theory have all in some way defended
pedophilia the uh Gail Rubin calls it um
called the intergenerational and these
are all things that if you want to go
and read the text in queer Theory this
is The Cutting Edge in sociology
departments I just got into an argument
today with a friend of mine not argument
but we were going back and forth on
Twitter and he's like this you know this
stuff isn't happening blah blah and I'm
like go look because I am not the one
that's asserting these things all I'm
doing is relaying the information that
are in books in sociology departments in
queer theory in LGBT studies in probably
in women's studies these are the ideas
that are in the sociology departments I
don't like them I don't want them to be
there I didn't put them there but don't
get mad at me because I know they're
there
when they say that it's not being taught
that nobody's talking about it that it's
not real there was an episode of the
good doctor in 2018 where they talk
about a person who has a desire for
interactions with children and they and
they in the episode they treat it with
empathy because he has not acted on it
and that's just to say 2018 we're
talking a very long time ago in that
when you really think about how long
that's been mainstream so it's not new
in any way shape no and they've tried to
change the language on this too right
they're calling pedophiles there's a
push to call them minor attraction
persons yeah exactly so I think you know
this is this proves that the slippery
slope is in fact very slippery I think a
lot of us especially me I was a little
bit more libertarian in my college days
I kind of laughed when Christian
conservative said you know pushing for
gay marriage is gonna open the
floodgates and it really has I mean look
at what we're dealing with today in just
a short amount of time
or the stories of people who get to a
guy gets to go to a woman's prison
because uh because he identifies a
different way it really is when you
allow that much subjectivity to the real
world bad things can happen I love the
uh why do you care so much
it's like Sheamus likes to bring that up
and then there was a so what happened
with the show we're supposed to do this
morning is that I made a comment that
was very dry
statement in my opinion about
um
the normalization of transgender
individuals and it was Kim Petras on the
cover of Sports Illustrated Swimsuit now
Kim is biologically male has undergone
many surgeries and the the image had Kim
halfway underwater so you could only see
half of the chest and up
and
in response to my Tweet someone said
something like
if if it wasn't for grifters like Tim
you wouldn't even know that these people
existed and my response was except for
when they're on the cover of Sports
Illustrated magazine and had like won a
Grammy this year and and right it was
singing with um uh Sam Smith no I'm like
I would love to talk about the Middle
East right now did you guys see Assad he
met with Saudi Arabia hey how about this
Saudi this year the Civil War is
basically over Assad one and him teaming
up with Saudi Arabia having this meeting
implies the Petro dollars on the way out
how about we talk about things like that
instead no but our culture is dominated
by people who are gutting it from the
ground up so I certainly want to talk
about it Sports Illustrated is actually
interesting because it is like the
hierarchy of what is acceptable in our
society right now there was four covers
there was the Kim Petras you have Tran a
trans individual you have Martha Stewart
so you got an 81 year old lady then you
have Megan Fox she her whole thing was
talking about uh body dysmorphia and
then there was just another lady named
like Brooke Nader Brooks Nader who I
wonder if she's related to Ralph Nader
because that would be very cool if that
was true but hers was just I won a
beauty contest and I like why can't we
talk about that this lady like beat out
10 000 other people to get this job
because that doesn't sell anymore
because there is no ESG funding in that
story there is no ideological way to
Virtue signal to people that you want to
build your base they're always looking
to build this Phantom audience the
people who are buying Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit editions don't care about Kim
Petras at least not if they're paying
attention and definitely don't care
about seeing Martha Stewart on the cover
but there's that's the hierarchy now you
have to be some type of oppressed group
you have to fit into affinity group
someplace for it to be relevant in the
culture the culture that they're pushing
on us do people still read these things
uh I mean I was trying to explain that I
was like you will not understand how
important this was as a symbol in the
90s maybe not So Much Anymore can you
get a tablet edition of it I have no
idea like I when you go to like a
Walgreens or a Walmart or something you
see the magazine section you'll notice
when you're checking out at Walmart the
magazines don't have names anymore it's
a thing so like
I see a magazine and it just said it
said Captain America all really big on
it and I'm like what magazine is this
and then really really tiny It's Time
Magazine
because it doesn't matter anymore they
know
nobody's buying their magazine what they
do know is or maybe maybe not time but
like the logo is really small people
will see oh I like Captain America I
will buy a Captain America thing and
then they're buying the magazine
because people aren't reading them
anymore no I mean and there is a certain
homogeneity of the message like you you
get GQ with you know trans men on it and
uh you know
what is it health with yeah fat ladies
on it and it's just yeah it's just the
total homogenization of the of the
message it doesn't matter if you're
picking up a rolling stone or if you're
picking up GQ or if you're picking up
you know women's health or whatever
you're getting the same message I it is
absolutely the same message I just going
back to whether or not this uh
these people can they're they're the
left can survive in the future I just I
just don't see it I just I I can't see
this stuff making its way into the
future because for one like I mentioned
it's self-destructive but people are not
like people so I'll put it this way
I made the joke on Twitter based off of
John Dies joke I said start
complimenting liberal women by saying
they look like they look like Dylan
mulvania or lizzo everybody immediately
understands what the what the what the
joke is while these liberal women will
say Dylan mulvania is beautiful or lizzo
is beautiful if you say you look just
like them they will get angry because
inside they know they're lying they
don't find these people attractive
that's the kind of thing that says to me
this cannot survive this cannot persist
the the culture they have of lying about
how they really really feel about things
everyone on the surface might lie but
then they won't actually act upon those
things those things will not exist yeah
they can go on and and and and on top of
that too
if you if they keep coming out and
saying people like lizzo are beautiful
like this is going to lead to a high
mortality rate for a lot of people
once again it is it is resulting in the
loss of life on the left the right is
more likely to be like cut out the sugar
stop eating seed oils how many how many
people how many times have you heard in
the past week stop eating seed oils like
come on the right won't shut up about it
then the microplastics but see like the
right whatever that is is trying really
hard to be healthy to be responsible I
got glass bottled water here we get it
for all our guests you do have plastic
because we you know we're not that crazy
we just try to do better
but if the long the long run the
trajectory just seems very simple the
left starts to disappear and the right
expands I get what you're saying but
like historically when we've seen these
kind of ideologies try to push for
influence and stuff there's Mass death
so you could be right there could be a
lot of people that end up dying that but
that's also something that happens Mass
death in which direction I mean well if
they get if they get in control if they
get into positions of power and actually
can decide can make policy then you're
going to end up seeing a massive push
for for the reduction of carbon usage
and the reduct and that means reduction
of energy usage they don't want to use
uh petrochemicals to to fertilize any
plants and stuff so you're going to see
famines of not just conservative or not
just left but conservatives why
conservatives because they're well it
would be a worldwide death because you
you'll see like you'll see significant
famine that would it can say they're not
going to start with the US it'll be in
places where that where there's already
on the edge of famine American
conservatives will be the last to go
sure sure and that and then what happens
20 years later conservative United
States I mean maybe so we can put it
this way
let's say
the there's two potential Forks the left
sterilizing and aborting their kids
they're promoting unhealthy Lifestyles
and promoting sterilization of
individuals over a long enough period of
time they just won't exist concerns well
let me finish that's one potential the
other potential is they gain massive
political power of the institutions take
over and then start culling their
opponents either way the Great Famine
whatever ends up happening as we often
see with big communist regimes the
Soviet Union lasted about 69 years and
then what happens it falls apart if it
does conservatives who tend to have
their own sources of food to a to a
greater degree than liberals that the
pressure is still apparent the left
taking over means famine and death but
it's the people in the cities who are
Urban liberals who are the first to
struggle and have no access to resources
conservatives are about the middle of
nowhere is nowhere with chickens goats
guns and a garden at the very least not
every single one will strive well I'm
sorry will Thrive but many of them will
be okay plus all the preppers are I
don't disagree with the ultimate result
like I don't think that the the the left
will ultimately win because I think that
constantly it eats itself and there's
all kinds of problems in the ideology
um it's I just don't think that it's
going to be any kind of uh smooth
sailing to get who's that it was smooth
sailing no I'm not I'm not saying it
could be the most catastrophic nightmare
scenario we could imagine but the end
result is the right wins I think likely
because I think that uh I think there's
there's Merit to your arguments about
the way that people on the right live
and the way that they organize their
lives and stuff but I'm looking at it
just like basic probabilities right you
you don't you bet not a horse race when
you bet on the long shot horse 40-1 you
win around 40 to 1. imagine if they were
like the horse that got a 40 40 to 1
chance to win and we'll give you you
know you bet 100 bucks we'll give you
ten dollars if you win you'd be like wow
I want to do that I'll like what I'm
gonna lose and even when I don't get
anything I'm looking at this right now
it's like the probability exists that
sure sure when you're looking at any
roll of the die we'll do that it's
possible that Snake Eyes comes up it
happens all the time but it's just one
in 30 rolls for it to happen so it's
unlikely I think it is very unlikely in
the long term the left succeeds they may
have short-term victories they may get
they they have many institutions I
believe right now but over a long enough
period of time it just fails because
it's not physically possible even if we
break it down to just simple economics
centralized command economies cannot
work right just unless there is some AI
takeover
yeah well I mean let's go with that
is it also fair to point out that
there's a difference between whether
we're talking leftist tactics in the
average neoliberal who will definitely
support a lot of these policies but are
raising kids that are still going to end
up in government still are having
traditional families they're just not
telling you that the things that we're
talking about are a problem right they
still support them they just don't it's
nimbyism they just don't support it in
their own backyard they're they're fine
with that like those kids yeah so the
the problem is that like yeah you could
in a lot of ways the The Fringe types
are going to find themselves eliminated
from the gene pool with their decisions
but the Nancy Pelosi's and the the rest
of the politi the politicians are still
having kids they're still expanding and
creating their own political oligarchies
in a lot of ways with their families I I
don't see if necessarily it goes away
that quickly I I think the establishment
people just do whatever they think earns
them power and if the left is removing
themselves culturally and physically
then you will Democrats will will gladly
come out they will gladly come out in
support for cutting taxes for the rich
if the power structures support that
idea it doesn't matter they they're
they're vanilla yogurt you know what I
mean just like whatever whatever's
happening in the world they'll say like
sure so
I think It ultimately comes down to we
have two big populist wave populist
waves and one is like not like everybody
on the right is healthy and fit but more
likely to be meritocratic more likely to
live in rural areas with better air with
access to at least some ability to get
their own food I mean look right right
now outside I can see all the mulberries
growing and we have those mock
strawberries it's really fun Have You
Ever Seen The Mock strawberries no I
didn't even know about these things I'll
move out here there are these little
tiny yellow flowers and they grow what
looks like strawberries on them and uh
you can eat them they're just flavorless
they're like pretty bland and no one
really cares for them but the chickens
eat them they they gobble them up so I'm
like I'm out here we got chickens we had
eggs we got berries we got the Paw Paw
fruits that are like crazy and we're not
even trying to have that food you live
in a city
there's no food outside you go to a
store you get your food or you don't out
here we have choices on walking outside
and finding things to eat if we so
choose then typically go to the grocery
store but putting it at that if Society
collapsed right now
we out here in the middle of nowhere
would have little bits of food in the
city they would have none
that's enough
people out here will sir are more likely
to survive than people in cities
not to mention all the pressures that
come from population density in those
places where everything when something
bad happens I am wrong they actually
have a lot more food in the cities than
we do out here each other exactly but
for real though there's no people out
here so it's like I gotta eat a deer we
got a lot of deer though there's so many
deer out here turkeys too how's your car
there sir uh I still haven't gotten
looked at but it's it's just annoying
there's too many they're everywhere you
had a deer yeah I had a deer uh going on
the highway when it was foggy today yeah
when recently uh yes on what was it
Monday Tuesday wow something right it's
just because it's foggy and there's
there's literally so many of them
they're like I think we gotta eat them
yeah literally I know you know I'm
trying to eat the chickens but my
brother doesn't want to eat any of them
he's like no we can't come on talk about
the the guys in the back of the well the
roosters for sure I've been trying to
make roosters stew for like a year but
my brother's like we can't eat them man
like the foxes are eating them like I
think a couple of them died
but they're mostly out okay we're King
Roberto is still all right he's in
retirement he's doing he's doing well
but I'm ready we got too many we got
babies now they had they make more of
themselves and then we give them scraps
we give them leftovers they eat bugs
it's because they're not turning their
kids into trans individuals they're
actually happy that they actually you
know well actually we mostly bread out
of the chickens the broodiness
so yeah it's actually not super easy the
silkies will have babies yeah the fluffy
chickens they they just they desperately
wanted babies and then we have a coach
in and she had two babies and so she
stands there with little babies very
cute you know and then one day we'll eat
them yeah because it's food and I have
no problems I don't care I'm like yes
they're cute yes I love my chickens and
they're also my food chickens are it's
really hard to love chickens they're so
stupid that's why I love them well I
mean like a dog I get it I get loving
book because I get loving a cat chickens
they're they're tough to love they're
nah well shame is funny Sheamus spent
two hours on our podcast talking about
how dogs don't have the capacity to love
yeah he's wrong yeah he's totally wrong
uh you see here's the thing about
Roberto Jr he walks around minding his
own business and he's a stand-up guy we
had we had leftover Sushi today and we
went out the sashimi and when we would
try and give some to him he would make
sure the girls got it instead he he
never he he always just like stands
above it he'll look down and the girls
will come and take it and they'll just
stand back up and he keeps watch what a
gentleman he is he watches guard all day
he's less concerned with having food for
himself he wants to make sure his girls
are all right
he's got a lot of girls there's no
chicken saying where have all the good
men gone
he's a good dude and see that's the
thing about chickens
roosters will sacrifice themselves did
you know this did not know that yeah
that's right well I I am offended by
people saying you know using the word
chicken to imply cowardice because a
rooster will charge to its death if it
means buying time of for the hens to
escape to safety wow that's braver than
most humans now somebody gets attacked
on a subway and they just don't
intervene exactly because the rooster
won't get the chicken won't get sued
well they don't want to get involved
this is why I want to donate to Daniel
Penny because he exhibited the the the
spirit of the noble rooster by defending
the people you should tell her somebody
should be told I mean the roost like I I
when I was reading about chickens I was
like wow no for real and then we had a
hawk attack an eagle or I think a hawk I
think we have Eagles out here a hawk
swooped in trying to get our chickens
and then Roberto his dad
a yelled runs to the door because we had
a caged up thing in the door they can
come to the Garden it soups in the
garden he runs out and stands guard in
front of it waiting for all the girls to
go in and then goes in last all right
dude these guys like these are standing
up dudes man they do let's let's jump to
the story from the National Review and
stop talking about chickens this is from
uh National Review lawyer for pregnant
NYC nurse involved in bike Feud vows to
sue media for defamation can I give you
money sir I know they have a GoFundMe
for her but I would provide some money
for a lawsuit against the media for a
lying the lawyer representing a pregnant
New York physician
assistant who whose confrontation with a
group of black men over a rented bike
led to her suspension from the hospital
plans to sue media Outlets to that cast
her as a racist Thief
Sarah Jane comrie got into an argument
last week with a few young black men who
claimed she was stealing a rental bike
they paid for video went viral this we
know she then released receipts NBC News
reviewed them too so now they've been
reviewed by everybody and they've all
confirmed that yep that was her bike
they even gone so far as to say you
can't rent the same bike out in Rapid
succession meaning the only way she had
the receipt is if she was the one who
was trying to get the bike in the first
place these dudes were trying to rob her
and the media attacked her Ben Crump you
got a suit what's this guy's name what's
his lawyer's name Ben Crump no no this
this lawyer for Sarah comrie Justin
Mourinho you gotta Sue Ben Crump for
defamation yeah yeah so they say a few
minor press outlets and uh and the black
men involved in the altercation claimed
that Camry was fake crying and stole the
bike multiple major press Outlets also
reported the video suggested she stole
the bike some online figures disparaged
comrade as a Karen a popular slang term
for a white woman who feels entitled to
special treatment we are going to get an
answer when we start filing defamation
lawsuits Marina told Fox news's Bill
hemmer she's been called a racist a
thief there are reasons defamation laws
exist and we plan to pursue that well
there is the a lot of the headlines on
Twitter it said appears to be stealing a
bike and it's like that word appears
it's literally prevent it's like the
shield preventing you from your library
from your from your lawsuit right so
like I said no matter how much you hate
the journalists you don't hate them
enough you really should hate them more
you cannot you can't hate them enough
they I love the Michael malice uh quote
about you know the job will be done when
the average journalist is looked at like
a tobacco lobbyist
that's the that's the respect they
deserve they're disgusting they want the
they're they want the race war yeah they
can't come soon enough the thing is like
I I know I talked about this on Twitter
the other day
um there was this this uh and then the
ndaa of uh 2012 the Smith modernization
Act of 2012. that allowed the federal
government to propagandize people that
coincides with the like the singularity
of everybody having a cell phone in
their pocket and having the Internet
connected to them the media jumped at
the chance to feed the people the story
that the government wanted and I can't
like the reason that there's so many
people that feel very homogenized one
way is because the federal government
has been shoving a narrative down our
throats and it's it is reflected in the
way the population looks at other people
you look at the way the left looks at
the right the whole like the uh what was
it the the not the disposables the
deplorables and all that stuff that goes
along with it they're just oh the race
they're all racist they're all this
they're all that and it's a narrative
that is shoved down everyone's throat
like we were talking earlier all the
magazines are the same it doesn't matter
if it's GQ or if it's time or if it's
rolling stone they're all shoving the
same message down their throat team
Vogue the federal government exactly
yeah giving young women communism since
like back for back for years exactly and
the narrative that's coming out of the
federal government is oh there's all
these it's the white nationalism is the
white nationalism is the biggest problem
in your your Maga neighbor is probably a
racist that hates you and etc etc all of
that is a propagandic message that is
coming straight out of the federal
government directed at the left because
that's the quote unquote nice uh opinion
and it's also the one that actually
empowers the government so of course the
federal government is going to promote a
narrative
that promotes P that says people should
endorse what the federal government
wants you know higher taxes and and more
power and authority to the federal
government so I I think that the that
has been a big part of the reason why
everyone seemed everyone on the left
seems to have the same opinion and knows
nothing about the right they don't know
anything about independence they only
know that the the what the left has been
told you know told to think essentially
I think too you know no one wants to
talk about it especially on the right
but there is 100 percent a racial caste
system that currently exists in this
country I mean this woman was
villainized she was called a burglar
every name in the book right because
she's the caricature of a Karen which is
a slur for white women who dare to you
know complain about the degeneracy that
they see in their communities
um that that just you know say I don't
want it to be this way and I think they
tried to Daniel Penny her they really
did they tried to throw her under the
bus she was fired from her job or I
think placed on yeah placed on leave
from her job and the media came after
her and you know who was in docked the
people who attacked her I mean it's just
totally backwards the media is out there
defending criminals Lawless gangs just
that are running the streets and I think
our law enforcement too you're seeing
selective enforcement here right you
have people that are allowed to behave
in a criminal Manner and then you have
people who aren't and often that is
whether you are right or left leaning
what does it matter when the prosecutors
when the DA's won't prosecute anyways on
a lot of these crimes doesn't matter
no it's crazy I mean we used to arrest
people for disturbing the peace and now
if you walk her no we did and now if you
walk around do you see yeah now if you
walk around DC there are homeless people
screaming and harassing you at almost
every corner that is interesting I was
looking at these photos
we were in Atlantic City and they have
these photos all on the wall at this one
uh this where this playset photos and
all and you could see everybody wearing
a suit like it's the boardwalk 1920 or
whatever and all the men and women are
dressed up and I was like they're
wearing three-piece suits the women are
all wearing this crazy outfit I'm like
that's kind of crazy they would arrest
you for disturbing the peace like very
rigid way of living I'm not advocating
for it but I am saying we used to have a
little bit more rules maybe we need a
little bit more rules it's a slippery
slope you gotta stop wearing the
three-piece suit out in public and all
of a sudden there's just crime going on
in the streets you stop wearing the
three-piece suit next thing you know is
a dude taking a dump right there in the
middle of the street that's how they
don't arrest these people
because you can't because they're
they're mentally you know they're
mentally ill and and
they should be institutionalized well
yeah the state at least at this point
the state can't just pick them up so I
mean there probably should be some kind
of law that even that I have a problem
with because like look the second you
throw somebody in the system let's not
pretend like any of these institutions
uh as soon as they get a hold the system
gets a hold of them it's very hard to
extricate yourself from that environment
because they're so corrupt so I'm that
this came up a lot when they were
talking about Britney Spears because
she's still acting absolutely ridiculous
I'm like it's her right to do that she's
not harming she's not harming anyone
she's not making good decisions but it
is her right as an American citizen to
make those bad decisions for herself but
the people that are doing these things
in the streets are doing things that are
harming other people but I still would
err on the side of caution of just
throwing them in asylums given that I
don't know if that's the answer yes but
hear me out I have an idea what if
in San Francisco
if you are caught taking a dump outside
they put you on a boat and bring you to
an island and then leave
so an island maybe in the Bible
but I'm not saying any prosecution I'm
saying if you are caught defecating in
the streets they put you on the boat
they bring you out they drop you off on
the island you're free to go they have
like no no there's no incarceration
you're not locked up they're just gonna
we're gonna drop you off right here and
that's it no more words I'm not here to
insult you we'll be on our way and if
you build a boat and come back from the
island then so be it otherwise
you know you're not locking anybody up I
mean you could you're not depriving them
of anything if they don't if they don't
live anywhere if they're if there's if
if they are if they're homeless with no
jobs and they're taking dumps on the
street why should in all seriousness the
question is this why should we as
Citizens and taxpayers of a city
tolerate people who aren't members of
our community
destroying our community right do we not
have the right to be like we are going
to place you outside you can always walk
back in we're not like but if we catch
you we're going to remove you again
because I know people who've gotten
banned from cities I've heard this
they're like you're not welcome here and
things like that but we don't do it for
people taking dumps in the street in San
Francisco yeah I assume they want that
though like the government likes that
it's happening they could arrest them
though and prosecute them but they won't
prosecute them and that's the big
problem here right what are they doing
at Epstein's Island they could use that
one there's Alcatraz is in San Francisco
Alcatraz just right out there it's
already there's buildings just don't
lock them up but there's already
buildings they can go inside they can
Shelter From the rain
if we give them like a big enough island
with like food and animals and stuff
it's like you have every chance to
survive in in this and it's a mini Exile
it's like mini it's like you can always
come back just swim I don't know
whatever it's up to you we're not we're
not telling you what you can or can't do
we're just leaving you here the island
to Catalina off of uh yeah there's a
fantastic reality show pitch in there
somewhere
we placed 100 homeless men on an island
like if MILF Banner is a thing then they
could absolutely do that for the number
one for the number of homeless people
that are in I mean just the greater San
Francisco area you need you'd need an
island the size of like Oahu like it
would have to be like a size the
question is
is it possible that what these people
might need is actual hardship
I mean probably they are where these are
people who are in places where they have
makeshift shelters free everything they
get money from the state they get they
get money and if they don't people are
giving them food they're getting food
somewhere somehow so there's no
requirements yeah this isn't it's an
it's enabling it's not helping them what
if the one thing these people need is
just to be in open land and say figure
it out and then all of a sudden they're
like hey I'm not getting food anymore I
better find food and then it starts
giving them responsibility and helping
them you know survive I'm not so so
confident that would work but I do think
there is value to the idea that human
beings are anti-fragile so we respond
well to adversity like literally our
bodies need gravity
to have for our bones to have the
Integrity to to hold our body together
so like we need to go and exercise to
keep our bodies in shape and we need to
have that resistance we need to strive
for things to feel like we are
accomplishing things that's something
that's important for human beings so I
don't know if I I don't know that I
agree that we can just go and toss them
into the Wilderness but I do think that
there is Merit the idea that human
beings need adversity to flourish the
homeless problem is one of the hardest
ones to discuss right because it gets
into the idea of body sovereignty it
gets into the idea of free will but then
you have to have these discussions where
they say oh just throw them in a hotel
just give them a hotel and everything
will be fine and the hotel is destroyed
two days later and it's one of the
hardest ones to discuss because there
really isn't a clean solution to any of
it yours might be the cleanest solution
to that type of thing but that's just
for the ones that are actually doing
something that's harming the the quality
of life of somebody else what about the
ones that aren't like what do you do
then then what if we just say like we as
a city reserve the right to remove
people from our boundaries
yeah they will never do it I think the
people in these cities like it I mean
well they I think the people in these
cities aren't of most of the time
they're not affected right like so
if there's like a million people in the
city and there's a thousand homeless
people that's a lot of homeless people
but it's not enough to have a negative
effect on everybody's life every day
enough where they're gonna be like hey
this is a big deal that's that's one of
the things I said in La is I said there
I saw this guy in a he was clearly
disabled he's driving driving a little
scooter thing uh I couldn't tell if he
was a paraplegic or quadriplegic but he
couldn't use the sidewalk that was built
for him in order to get down the street
because there's literally so many
encampments so he's driving on the road
and cars are like dodging him down 6th
Street it's just like yeah I thought you
guys were about you know caring for
people that are disabled and Etc but
you're not okay here's another idea what
if
we take homeless people there like after
after a certain amount of infractions
maybe three
if they're sleeping outside and it's
like hey you can't sleep outside this is
your first warning don't do it again
then we catch them like defecating it's
like look this is your second time third
time you know it's gonna happen third
time they get placed in government
housing where their food and shelter is
taken care of they will be clothed and
fed but they have to do work that we
prescribe and they're not allowed to
leave
no I I do I mean there's How about if
someone takes a crap on the street we
prosecute them and put them in jail you
think that I think so what do you think
I mean absolutely yeah that would be
ideal but unfortunately that's not the
way that our society or legal system is
currently running and I think people
have come to accept this as The New
Normal yeah I mean so many young people
that I meet in DC in cities like Chicago
or New York they don't know any
different this is this is what they're
used to you see that's so sad at the
Oscars this year like they just put up
big fake walls so that you couldn't see
the homeless people well the celebrities
were walking down that is the gross that
is the grossest thing
that is it's the most nimbing thing in
the world it is so gross they did clear
them out for a couple of days they're
like you can come back after the event
you know you know what I think benefited
me greatly as a kid is that I went to
Catholic school for the from
kindergarten I was homeschooled then I
went to Catholic School from
kindergarten until fifth grade started
sixth grade at Public School those kids
in public school did not know it was
possible the kids at the Catholic school
I thought were very like hoity-toity and
like very high strung but at the
Catholic School everything's more
ordered yep I went to Catholic School
from from kindergarten until uh seventh
grade or say no yeah seventh grade so
there's a lot of people who don't know
that things can be really really good
they don't they they never they've never
experienced they don't know it's
possible Well yeah if you if you're born
into that environment you just adjust to
it accordingly and then you never really
look outside that they talk about a lot
of people who grew up in inner cities
who never who never travel more than a
couple blocks from their house they've
never seen any and that's just that's
something you could get away with in a
car right like they could drive to get
there but they don't drive you know
they've never owned a car they've never
been someplace other that shows them
that there's more things that are
possible that's kind of where in a lot
of ways I feel like a lot of that the um
how we talk about going away to college
like that's what that's become for a lot
of for a lot of kids like they get a
scholarship because they want to go away
and experience something different of
course colleges now are not exactly what
they used to be but a lot of people just
they never learned that there is a world
outside of what they're used to
yeah yep and then what ends up happening
is they keep voting for what they think
is the only thing it's the funniest
thing to me we had Lance on and um the
conversation around Daniel penny and I
don't know if it was him but uh it might
have been AOC saying something like
you know the the right keeps blaming
mental illness for all these things when
the Republicans defund these mental
illness blah blah I'm like what
Republican is running New York City
this is this is run by like all of these
issues black lives matter police it's
all Democrat cities it's the craziest
thing to me when they're like we want to
defund the police I'm like yeah okay
y'all are in a Democrat Democrat City
defunding the places no no issue does
nothing to my Sheriff's Department I
don't care yeah the left is complaining
about
what they voted for it is the it is the
craziest thing as well they're in
democrat-run cities complaining about
problems that are born of their policies
it's like watching a toilet get flushed
and I'm just sitting there being like
there it goes they just it's just
spinning around and around around they
keep doing the same thing and then
complaining about it I remember arguing
with kids in L.A that were saying like
oh it's still these all these Republican
Senators these Republican congressmen
like there's numerous Senators do you
understand how many there are like you
don't have any idea dude you're in L.A
yeah the senator can't change what's
happening in La that's your city
government
people are so ignorant about the about
what they are upset about yeah it's they
have no idea that the most effective
things that they can do are things that
they do locally you know the things that
are going to have the biggest impact on
their daily lives are going to be things
that they you know can do locally Joe
Biden is not going to be able to do
anything and it isn't interested in
doing anything to make your life better
like not at all so to and I really wish
that you could get people to like not
just hear that but actually internalize
and be like all right if I want to make
my life I want my life to be better I
have to do things whether it be acting
locally or maybe it's it's you know
taking some you know taking some agency
in your own life and going out and
trying to do some stuff there's a lot of
people that have rough lives but they
also get so wrapped up in the fact that
their life is rough that they're not
gonna they feel like they can't do
anything about it so if you feel like
you have no agency and you can't do
anything you're not going to try in uh
in in Minnesota post George Floyd
um in uptown you know a lot of these
places were the same ones that held
events advertising defund the police you
know which leads to a lot of lawlessness
in the city and what would happen is
graffiti would be put up on all of the
buildings uh you know all of the shops
in uptown and then the city would come
through and they would say you need to
clean this up in the next seven days or
we're going to clean it up for you and
we're going to charge you 700 800 to do
it and of course because you know the
cops have pulled back because of all of
the negative press that's going on at
that time graffiti goes up they get uh
they get hit with a 700 fine when
somebody has to come clean it up for
them and it never seems to make it to
their brain that you voted for the
policies that are enabling you going out
of business they don't understand that
because I don't know if they think that
deeply Beyond just either whatever the
wedge issue is and whatever the emotion
that that very skilled politician has
done has been able to do in making you
feel angry about it and that's a problem
I want to jump to this story give you
guys some uh some optimism here cyclists
no show post-race Podium after
biological mail finishes first in female
race that's the story take a look at
this picture the women refuse to show up
so I think this is the start of
something good there's a another story
that we have I think it's uh maybe it's
this one
losing to a trans writer hurts on a
million different levels 24 year old
cyclist abandons Olympic dream after
sickening losses to biological male and
protests from antifa Gun Club not only
that that's terrible but apparently this
biological male who won physically
attacked oh yeah another writer this is
in yes this is this is wild
um there's a video from uh was posted on
April 26th it's from cyclocross yeah
cycle across and the the biological male
Riley Gaines tweeting it physically
attacks and tries to knock down a woman
and then that woman never races again
yeah crazy see they don't they they find
all the ways to get the performance in
enhancing drugs out of them so now they
just have to go and compete against
women well I mean take a look I mean
this is uh uh good for these women I've
been saying this yeah stop showing up
that's a dude and so this is a
biological male who won the women's
cycle uh race and the other women are
like the females are like no we're not
gonna We're not gonna go on the podium
it's also like remember when um they had
it was uh Leah Thomas one but then the
other one refused to stand next to Leah
Thomas I think that might have been
Riley Gaines right not entirely sure if
that was so this is this is the kind of
stuff that I'm talking about with I
don't think the left I left ideology can
actually survive it's like saying you
can build a you can build a building
imagine these people tried building a
building
and just imagine what happens I think
everyone goes oh okay now I understand
like it's not gonna stand up it's gonna
be crooked it's going to be slumping
over on one side and it may stand for a
little bit they may have guards
surrounding it with guns they may not
let you come in they may in fact kick
you out of your own building nearby but
sooner or later that thing comes
crashing down because there's there's a
logic in order to building a system
they can come out and claim all you know
what's happening
these people have started building a
structure and then all of their friends
are going your structure is so amazing
it's although you don't who needs
i-beams we don't need support columns
like what are you talking about and then
they're like very happily toting along
building this thing and then one day
just crumbles because no one actually
believes it they're just trying to keep
their head down nobody wants it's the
emperor having no clothes nobody wants
to be the person to tell the king he's
naked well that's what happened with
Chernobyl no one wanted to say hey
there's a problem they were afraid to
tell people and because of that that
made the the Meltdown you know so much
worse I I if I understand correctly the
Meltdown could have been uh could have
been prevented if they would have
actually had the uh the balls to tell
the people in charge that there was a
problem but they were afraid to tell
that there's a problem with the with the
nuclear reactor nobody wanted to be that
person who was removed from the
photograph was Stalin yeah exactly I
don't know what that guy you know guys
what was his deal you know that Meme
though right yeah I don't know I don't
know what the I don't know the
particular story behind but I know that
that's impressive multiple people that
happened to multiple people yeah he
would de-person them and have his
artists like the Soviet artists just go
through and remove them and repaint the
picture just like you do now with like a
smartphone and like in like Photoshop
Etc just literally do Photoshop in 1930s
and that's that's actually impressive
back then you know what I mean it's
great I mean essentially that's what
canceling is now it's the same thing
it's the same idea it's it's a little
bit different than you know actually
killing people but like when you cancel
someone you remove them from polite
society and they're you know their
pariahs and people don't want to
associate with them and and so it's it's
the same thing but a digital but in a
digital you know world as opposed to
just see like an actual clone stamp tool
in the 1930s to just remove people from
the portrait that's amazing it's really
impressive I mean interior cancel
culture point though like I feel like
more
things like this happening is
effectively you know canceling this
trans ideology that's running rampant
across our country and I think as
conservatives for a long time we've been
very scared to kind of embrace cancel
culture but I honestly think you know
there are some things that we should
cancel there are some things that are
not conducive to like good Society
cancel culture was always the left
digging up a tweet from someone from 10
years ago and getting them fired right
and so then we saw stuff like Mike
cernovich pulling up jokes from James
Gunn and then James Gunn got suspended
he got fired hired back that's it's not
cancel culture to be like hey we don't
want women's sports to be dissolved
right but I do think you know we've
bought into this fallacy of like the
marketplace of ideas and every opinion
should be heard and it's a great opinion
opinions like this you know are damaging
to people it should not be heard it
shouldn't be told dear children are
encouraged in schools or anything like
that so you know I think there always
will be some Orthodoxy that's enshrined
in the Public Square there is no such
thing as like living Let Live do what
you want something is going to dominate
the culture so we need to make sure that
what's dominating the culture is
something that's good and going to
encourage our society to you know just
like do well and to help people and and
let people live freely and and great I I
agree to a great deal I I I'll push more
on the freedom of speech component of
this in that we don't we don't want
these people secretly indoctrinating
kids we want them to come out show the
book and then we can be like and here's
why they're wrong because otherwise
they'll find creepy ways to do it but I
suppose the fair point is it's better
that you remove most overt ways of doing
it and then they're probably in the
shadows even right now you know what I
mean so I think my my realization came
when um partly from a lot of this that
it doesn't matter what your principles
are it matters where your moral line is
so the left argues they think parents
have the absolute right to determine
what's best for their kids
but then they don't care that schools
are saying don't tell your parents the
right says parents have the absolute
right to determine what's right for
their kids but the government should
intervene if a parent tries to give
their kid a sex change both groups will
argue a similar the same sentence but
then perform it in different ways and
it's it's similarly after Scott at to
how Scott Adams says we're all watching
one screen but seeing two different
movies if that's the case
you have to realize
moral framework is what unites a people
I mean I think if no culture you have no
country yeah and that's completely true
right now in the United States there's
no cohesive culture I mean we can't even
agree on what a woman is so yeah no
there's no founding value system that
everybody prescribes to but this is what
we have to realize we can agree on what
a woman is it's just that there is a
psychotic death cult that can't but why
are we acting like we're on par with
them imagine you were the CEO of a large
media company and the guy who runs the
hot dog stand downstairs starts
demanding you debate him because he's a
CEO as well it's like well well come on
look man I'm managing 3 000 employees in
this building we're managing assets in
the billions of dollars you have a small
business which I respect but you you are
not in a position where you're going to
tell me so this guy running hot dog
stand is like you're completely wrong
about interest rates let me tell you and
it's like
look man
your ideas about what an interest rate
is he comes out and he says interest
rates are not mathematical they're
alphabetical and you're like okay that
makes literally no sense well I insist
it's true then a bunch of his buddies
show up in demand you do a TV interview
debate no no no no no come on if
somebody wants to come out and argue
they don't know what a woman is or make
some nonsensical claim we should just be
like you are a fringe group of people
this is the argument they make don't
platform these people it's like I'll say
the same thing back why should we
entertain their opinion
it's tough because I was again I was
just having the same kind of
conversation today with a friend and
he's like you know he had an issue with
me complaining about Communists which
suppressed president complaining about
communism weird but
um he had an issue and he's like well
you know blah blah blah this person that
person he starts talking about the right
having uh the the extremist far right
having access to power and I'm like what
are you talking about the extreme is far
right and then he's like well Tucker
Carlson and and uh Alex Jones and and
it's like these people are not Extreme
as far right he's associating them with
Nazis and he's saying well you know uh
you know that Nazi kid had dinner with
uh with Trump and it's like well Trump's
kind of a for doing that that was
a that's a terrible idea Milo's the guy
that made it happen but like
the idea that the far right actual Nazis
have influence in the culture is to me
ridiculous like everybody has their
Spider Sense super tuned in for Nazis
but no one does for Communists but he
the way he sees it is like the
Communists are all Fringe and they have
no power I'm like AOC and Bernie and you
know there's one simple way to test
whether or not the right is the call to
the left but this speaks to the the two
the the one movie two different screens
well so so I thought about this a long
time ago I'm like you know these people
keep saying Trump supporters are all an
occult and I'm like well I I want to
make sure there's a check on my reality
I I don't want to be trapped in a bubble
am I wrong on this one
let me let me ask you Kingsley do you
think that you can be a conservative and
pro-choice
no most conservatives I ask say that
they say that that's like one of that's
like the hardest line on what makes a
conservative
the left literally argues with me
calling me Far Right despite my opinion
on abortion being traditional Democrat
pro-choice
yet conservatives will be like oh that's
the liberal position we'll have a
conversation will disagree Sheamus and I
will make jokes all day and then
disagree on very strong issues
if you understand the differences
between
a conservative and me you're not an
occult
but the left can't tell the difference
at all they see everybody in this room
and they see far right it's the meme
yeah where they're in the they're
they're in the Communist tanky corner
and everyone else is a Nazi and it's
like if you can't see the difference in
politics between Brett me Luke
Ian James I mean Luke and Sheamus's
politics are also very very different
and we come on this show we have
eclectic voices and then we talk about
it they can't tell the difference I
spent the I spent half the day with like
my my mentions full of like cowboy come
Hunter Fans complaining of that because
I made a joke about you know about him
and and the other time was arguing with
a left-leaning guy about me being
associating with far-right people while
the far right you know the the Nazis are
in my in my mentions calling me a Jew
lover like literally just like you're a
Jew and I'm like oh I don't have a
problem with Jews but I'm not Jewish no
I love that yeah the the person who kept
super chatting being like when when will
you answer someone did a review and
found that like 25 of all the guests on
the show are Jewish or something like
that I don't even know that's true and
they're just like can you explain this
and I'm like what I don't even explain
it was there was there a number that was
the correct number right look look if
you think there are too many Jewish
people on timcast IRL up your game do
something worthwhile and get on Tim cast
IRL stop complaining that there are
people that are doing things that are
Jewish on IRL did anyone do a breakdown
on how many Christians come on this show
I am not a Christian but we have a very
very heavy disproportionate amount of
Christians who come on the Show and
Sheamus literally talking about like sin
and God and faith and stuff regularly
but nobody comes on be like how come you
have so much God love on your show Tim
and then Ian is some kind of like he was
what was he an atheist
it's not anymore I don't know he talks a
lot about God and the importance of it
but he's certainly not very soon he's
elevated to a higher being now
yes well yeah I mean that that's what
happened I mean uh the reason he's not
here is because he ascended to a higher
plane of existence he's actually above
us right now yeah we're hoping he comes
back part of the reason for that is it
really is true that I think if you have
anything you know right of you know what
is now far left in society which is now
you know the Overton window has shifted
so far that what is normal if you're
anything to the right of that you're
challenged on a daily basis with your
media with the news that you into you
know that you choose to partake in
you're constantly having your viewpoints
checked because there are people that
you're going to be watching whether it's
on social media whether it's the news if
you're in an airport and you're watching
CNN whether it's the the television in
the movies you watch which are all at
the very least liberal Orthodoxy if not
left in the far left going further left
you're constantly being challenged
therefore you're forced to on a regular
basis see the ideas of people you may
disagree with and that kind of hardens
your core to be able to take those
Concepts internalize them understand
what they're saying still understand
what your position on it is and either
make your argument back or just accept
that that person believes what they want
to believe and that's fine the people
that fall into the Dogma that is the
left now they get news that reaffirms
their beliefs they get movies that
reaffirm their beliefs they get music
that reaffirm their beliefs they aren't
really ever exposed to viewpoints that
they don't agree with and when they do
it's on social media and it becomes a
refast where they argue with you buy and
then and then they block you or they or
they turn off their mentions or since
you can't respond they get so destroyed
in a chat they have to go to the
hospital
I mean that's that's that's another
great point that I didn't bring up to my
friend that I should have brought that
kid went to the hospital yeah poor guy
has did you see you saw that yeah that's
insane this it was a Nuance bro owned a
a leftist so hard he checked himself
into the emergency room to the ICU and
they gave him like an IV for for fluids
and stuff like what did I thought that
was a I thought it was fake he shouldn't
I thought he was joking he should have
never told that because now Nuance
broken like wear that badge forever
which there will be merch for that
for sure there will be I'm worried now
about having Nuance broke him in because
he might he might put us all in the
hospital you know I mean seriously
seriously hurt us with his men he should
sell risk like Hospital wristbands
you hear I'm sure someone can tell them
don't tell him yeah I survived a debate
with nuance
bro you get a hospital that's a
wristband that says I survived
and that is that is actually a really
good merch idea that would be great do
it new ones bro come on man yeah you got
to do that man that's good but it's kind
of crazy that he didn't he didn't
actually do that much he just told the
kid he was wrong well I mean he was so
so dramatically wrong and I like it kind
of makes sense why like if you think
that's going on which I can't imagine
well for those of none of the context
the kid said that 30 of black people
were being killed every year by police
and he was like they would be gone in
three years be no black people left and
it's that's crazy yeah and it's because
of you know it's because of the The
Narrative that comes out that again is
constantly shoved down people's throat
from the left and you people like again
like even LeBron James I brought it up
the other night he's talking about you
know we're hunted in the streets it's
like that is so far from true and it's
so hyperbolic that people I it it's no
wonder why there are like people that
are low information that are like man
I'm gonna die there's streets of
Calabasas
if it was true that police were killing
30 of black people every year this show
would be called antifa IRL and I would
be one of the most I would one of the
most prolific organizers resisting all
of that and fighting to stop it it's
incredibly ridiculous I mean but anyway
so that's the context and this kid ends
up checking himself into a hospital it's
it's crazy because he learned the world
wasn't as bad as he thought he even says
is 15 to 20 fair and they're like no
what no million millions of people is
not fair that's just not fair millions
of people being shot and killed in the
streets every year innocent like not
happening but he genuinely thought that
this is what happens when these kids
grow up in the internet cult yeah they
and they think this stuff and when you
look this stuff up even if you were to
go to look up the statistics you have to
go four to five like Pages down before
you actually get to any type of
demographic data and before that all you
get is New York Times articles Los
Angeles Times articles and they're all
over the top yeah and they all have the
headlines that we all know that are
designed to you don't even get past that
you get to the headline and you get
scared and you get angry and you don't
actually look for further information
I'm just from now on I'm gonna say that
oh that was a defect
so now if they're like didn't you see
that video of that guy and I'll be like
which one in the back that right-wing
guy that was a deep fake you didn't see
that that was fake that's just it's not
real anymore nothing's real you're wrong
deep fake sir my sources are real videos
your sources are all defects next
question yes that's for sure great
technique well because you know I'm
thinking I'm like in 10 years we won't
be having these conversations because
nothing will be real anymore yeah it'll
be it'll be AI doing it for us no no
it's not that it's that you wouldn't no
you won't be able to know we're we're
very very close to the point where you
just can't know
I mean do you guys see that video that
photograph of trump running through DC
with Sonic the Hedgehog like was that
real I can't tell I can't tell no that
was obviously obviously fake but uh
because Sonic didn't look real his hair
was off but um they should have used the
Sonic from the original design from the
movie that everybody hated so much well
I just asked mid journey to do it I
can't tell it to make it like use bad
Sonic from his bad Sonic with the weird
teeth don't look up bad Sonic either on
on the internet that's a whole nother
thing that you don't know but but my
point is right now we still have the
ability to know what's true and what's
not but it's getting harder and we are
standing on the edge about to experience
something crazy
in a few years I think even next year
when there's 8 000 videos of trump doing
weird things and you can't tell if it's
real or fake it's gonna be hard actually
let me pull this story up and I'll tell
you about what's going on right here uh
let me let me jump to timcast.com real
quick
so and I'll explain where what I'm
talking about we have this story
right here take a look at this
from timcast.com feminine hygiene
dispenser vandalized in Oregon high
school boys restroom one parent told Tim
cast news putting feminine products in
the boys bathrooms is just asking for
the types of incidents to happen
so we see this photo
let me uh let me pull up the tweet and
our our journalistic team reached out to
the school and two parents got
confirmation got an email saying this
did happen I saw this photo and said
this is a fake photo I do not believe
this is a real photo it does not look
real the why is it grainy why is the
lighting so strange it looks like a bad
Photoshop and it's intentionally low res
so that you you can't see where the
seams are apparently it's real we like
we actually have I think uh two
different two different uh confirmations
that this did happen we're wondering
though if someone faked the photograph
to go along with the story that
originated from an email who took the
photo does it uh our team is working on
it right now actually because I asked
him I was like are we are we do we know
for sure there's just a teacher there
with like an iPhone 4. and so what we're
saying is we do have an email from the
school where they said this happened and
it's been happening quite a bit but I
don't know if I believe this photo is
real maybe it is maybe it isn't that is
the issue first I'll say this according
to the email that we got and speaking to
one of the parents it looks like high
school boys are ripping down feminine
hygiene products because they're putting
in the boys room for some reason so
that's kind of funny and based but um
you know kids shouldn't vandalize things
let's put it at that the kids are
clearly protesting and this is their
right and uh but but I don't think it's
real like this Photograph doesn't seem
real to me at the very least I'm not
sure if it's real or fake and that's all
that matters come next year there will
be photos of Donald Trump and you're
going to be like Reasonable Doubt I have
no idea yeah there's enough doubt there
and there's no way to confirm it and
there's no way to debunk it these AI
Checker checking things that I just
don't know that they can actually do it
there was uh one post I saw where a
person said he got accused of using chat
GPT to write a college essay and he was
he was he was posting about how he did
not and the teacher used a program that
claimed a paragraph Was AI generated and
when he said it's not they said we'll
change it then and no matter what he did
it kept claiming it was AI generated so
what he'll have to like write it right
in front of them so they can actually
physically see him write it yep but more
importantly
you're gonna see a video of trump and
you're going to be elected that really
happen and the fact that you don't know
and have doubt means we won't be able to
have a conversation about a look I
wonder if it happened I have no idea
maybe what happens is Trump actually did
a bunch of bad stuff and he waits until
then he's got plausible he releases them
all at that time
you already had that story that one of
the krasensteins is on video saying he's
getting paid to troll basically and then
he said he came out and said that was a
clip from a skit that we were doing like
a like a like a bit and it's taken out
of context is it he could be lying yeah
he could be telling the truth
but I don't know why he would do a
hidden camera bit like that that's kind
of weird
like why would you do that the fact that
you can already say things like this and
people are going to believe it means
we've been in the post-truth era for a
long time I mean think about how long
ago it was when we had the very fine
people thing and and nobody just did any
research further nobody said hmm this
clip is cut at a very interesting place
they've had ways of doing this in the
media for a long long time it's just
going to be a lot easier for people to
fake it
there's gonna be pictures of Biden doing
weird stuff
but I mean like there's plenty of Super
Cuts on the internet if you want to see
Biden doing weird stuff but I mean like
it's gonna it's gonna get heavy that's
it's gonna get heavy that's the so
that's one of my worries is that the
government says look we can't people
can't discern between what is true and
what is not anymore so we can't have
elections or we can't you know like
that's something that I think is within
the cards like the government deciding
we can't have like people can't make the
distinction between what is real and
what isn't governments can't do it
anymore because AI generates things that
AI can't detect or whatever so that
means that we can't allow people to make
decisions for themselves and I don't
know that like I don't know that that
that is something that would happen but
I if I can conceive of the argument some
power hungry scumbag can definitely
conceive of the argument so I don't
again I don't know if that'll happen but
it's it's something that I wouldn't be
shocked in any way if there was some you
know somebody saying look we can't trust
our eyes and our ears so you got to let
the government take care of you because
you know they'll bring back that
disinformation governance board
as long as she debunks all the
misinformation and disinformation by
singing musicals that's good then I'm
okay with it wait didn't they put Kamala
Harris in charge of the isn't she the
aisar she's yeah when she's not
literally opening the door for people to
come into the country borders are and
the AIS we are screwed yeah hey eyes are
that's what that's I'd rather have the
AI be in charge yeah you know something
about being on a flashlight don't laugh
it won't be quite as annoying when it
laughs at you yeah though I I will say
one of my favorite things recently is
there's this guy who makes uh AI videos
of the last three presidents singing
together those are great uh it's Biden
Trump and Obama singing like rap songs
together it's fantastic so I mean have
you ever have you ever listened to the
Donald Trump sings yeah oh Maestro's
ecos on YouTube oh he's fantastic his
cover Donald Trump singing Blinded by
the blinds fantastic yeah that's really
good let's uh let's let's pull that it's
cut together with like actual like it's
not AI it's literally he's taken from
interview pieces which means it must
take thousands of hours to make that
here you go I'll just play a second of
it
[Music]
Maybe
I'm going through it wrong
you don't even have to go too much it's
amazing
[Music]
he's amazing
half that guy's channel is just those
videos I know it's amazing they're good
so long to do but you mean to tell me
that that's not actually Donald Trump
singing this the the one of him singing
See You Again by Wiz Khalifa is
incredible it's like an AI generated
version of it it's amazing
but I mean I think Donald Trump sings
Havana that's his most popular one
there's a Taylor Swift one that's also
really good
Havana
do you mean this is not real
[Music]
in them
[Applause]
that's so good I think he watches these
at like two in the morning
[Music]
people Google themselves I bet you he
Googles himself
[Music]
that's so good
there's something there's something
about in Spanish
brilliant I think his latest stuff is
like Joe Biden
Joe Biden sings in Chinese and he had uh
what is this uh Ella Baila Sola covered
by Trump see the thing is like during
The Last of Us presidential version his
videos are getting way more hits when
Trump was president and now he's got
like this Biden sings in Chinese 23 000
views
[Music]
this is like really hard to make too oh
yeah pulling up every clip of trump
saying a word such a pain yeah it's like
if people are like the reason it's not
popular now like it was a lot more funny
when I had money and I could afford to
put gas in my car it's not quite as
funny this time I can't afford food now
so so here's the problem though Maestro
zicos did all this work to make these
songs and we're about a year away from
you opening up your phone pressing the
voice to text and saying
render me a video of Donald Trump
singing blinding lights and then it will
just be like rendering and then boom and
it'll sound perfect I mean I've like I
admit to being in like I've been
watching a lot of like the like there's
a bunch of Kanye and Britney Spears AI
songs which is them performing songs
that they never sang and it's like at a
certain point we're just there now right
like you don't even have to actually
make the music
that weekend uh uh weekend and Drake
song is that what you're talking yeah
they they made an AI version of it and
it went viral yeah it's like music is
done yeah pretty much but I I suppose if
you own the rights
you're going to be good for a long time
because like Phil all you got to do is
tell it write me some new All That
Remains and then it will and you'll and
then you you have a render 100 different
songs then you go through them and say
these these five are good that's the new
album and then you're done in 10 minutes
I mean I I I assume that I would I'm
actually I'm not sure that I would
actually even bother going to track it
if if AI can do it yeah no you said yeah
well there's there was actually AI
rappers that companies were creating and
giving record deals I remember that FN
Mecca was like something like it was
just created by a company right and they
have uh AI activists now like AI social
media influencers that have actual
causes that they champion because
they're created by corporations but
you're just an avatar you you didn't
know that Brett yeah yeah yeah AOC not
even real not even real uh Greta tunberg
AI that's right yeah that's perfect
sense yeah I mean for all we know have
you ever seen him have you ever seen him
in real life Alex Stein I can tell you
he's not real yeah yeah that's how
that's how they did the the video of
Alex and an AOC together because they're
both computer generated so when uh you
know when whenever we've had Alex on the
stage people don't realize it's it says
some kind of Greens in a green screen
suit I would believe that AOC is
actually created in a lab she's like
she's the perfect like antithus
antithesis of uh Donald Trump we should
actually do that bit with uh with Alex
Stein it's like you see him on stage but
then we do a separate video where it's
just a guy in a green suit dancing and
rapping like it's not there's no Alex
not he's AI generated
yeah Ian Israel though
Ian's not it's not real yeah his brain
may be attached to the computer but
balloons
you know the weirdest thing about the AI
is um I was talking to my brother he he
said he's like did you ever put nothing
into mid-journey and I said yeah and
made a bunch of hot air balloons and he
was like yeah that's what it does for
real I guess for whatever reason if you
go to Mid journey and you give it
nothing I did a blank space I wrote null
in Brackets and I did one with like a
period or a single letter or whatever it
just makes a bunch of hot air balloons
hmm yeah weird pictures just mostly hot
air balloon I wonder if it's because
there's a ton of hot air balloon
pictures on the internet with no caption
that wouldn't just be programmed in
there from the I don't know stocking you
know what I was I was wondering too
though about like I wonder if you can um
if you can code inject into the AIS
code inject yeah so like they've done
prompt injections and I think this is
probably a simple no most people
probably understand this already so uh
uh like SQL injection is a rudimentary
way to break into uh uh websites because
what you need to imagine is when you're
at a website and it says username and
password and you see those two boxes
imagine behind the websites front door
or whatever the wall all that code is
there and then the code stops and the
username is blank and it keeps going and
the username stops and it's blank and
you putting in those words are adding to
the code of the website so if you insert
into those boxes more strings of code
you can change what the whole program
does so people were fine people could
break into websites by instead of
putting a username they would literally
write code so I'm wondering if you can
write code into some of these AIS and
then have it do things they wouldn't
normally do right I guess you'd have to
know what their code is first and know
what they're like you'd be able to see
the source code first to know how to do
it yeah
like an input no idea but how about we
go to super chats ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com to support our work
because we uh we do enjoy uh doing the
work and we appreciate your support but
you can also go to castbrew.com and buy
coffee
man I gotta tell you I did not uh it's
not easy doing the coffee thing we are
running behind we produce coffee we sell
it out we gotta throw money in it takes
a long time and then so like we've
invested heavily uh heavily into this
coffee shop a lot but uh it's it's
turning around and we think we're trying
to find that sales equilibrium where we
can see where our balance point is at
then grow slowly but we're growing so
rapidly it's costing us a lot of money
but uh thank you for your support Let's
uh smash that like button we'll read
some of your super chats I'm not your
buddy guy so I was very excited for
Monday's guest and despite having
opposing views on certain topics such as
country polling Integrity with you I
truly appreciate supporting you and your
team over at timcast thank you very much
good sir uh who do we have on Monday
Phil Dan bongino oh yeah I believed Dan
bongino is going to be here so uh we
normally don't like announcing because
then if they can so everyone gets let
down but uh very excited at first I was
like do you really want me to say it I'm
not sure I said really well you know
because like especially if it was
someone like Dan if he gets busy and
then he's like hey look something came
up people are like oh you know and then
it's just like well you know sometimes
people don't make it people don't make
it you know we were supposed to have uh
Kelly cadigan on the culture War podcast
this morning but uh uh that didn't
happen due to me posting tweets about my
opinions on fact-based issues yeah
thanks for the day off man
I actually I said I was like what if Tim
just woke up he's like I don't really
feel like doing it today it's like says
something else it's like but it's like
it's not even that offense it's crazy
I'm like this is the Centrist take on
this yeah
it's wild yeah whatever let's read some
more super jets all right
where are we at
essay Federal he says man I've never
laughed this hard alone until the Don Jr
show and Colby after show juxtaposed
that with s Libs Primal screaming with
their miserable friends white pills as
far as the eye can see I do think my
favorite moment of the uh show we did
with Don Jr is that when Sheamus started
promoting his uh his show Trump uh don
Jr is just like I am a trump like it was
almost like a how dare you try to out
promote with me in the room he was
trying to be polite I would have figured
if he knew that like that's the time to
go ahead and plug your stuff and like
Seamus is like then he Sheamus starts
and he's just like wait a minute here
it's like well you had your chance man
no one is stopping you yeah and Hannah
Claire was promoting Tim cast he's like
wait a minute
Trump
that was good
for this self-promotion I also liked
when he was talking about tweeting and
then he was like he would get a call
from the White House after tweeting
something and he's like I learned it
from you Dad
so good
from you
all right we'll grab some more yeah it
was fun but I recommend if you guys
haven't checking out the members only
show from yesterday
with Colby Covington because uh I go to
great detail as to why we had no culture
War show this morning and it is very
informative
um I think you should check it out and
we were hilarious all right guys I mean
I was just like
I thought I was very academic the whole
time I thought it was hilarious although
I did say some things that were abrasive
with the intention to explain why I
don't say those things but uh let's read
some more
j marie says 1984 teaches us that it
doesn't matter what the truth is what
matters is what's on the public record
Marie thesis podcast thank you for the
show for the Super Chat
purple says Tim best drug dealer cast
Brew life
we're working on a bunch of commercials
and one of them we want to do we were
considering was doing a coffee
commercial like a drug commercial
so it's like do you feel tired
lacking Focus or depressed perhaps cast
brew coffee is right for you and then
having someone like it's like gray and
they're like in the office and they're
sad and then you know the doctors like
looking and taking notes and then hands
them a cup of coffee and then they drink
it and they're like yeah and then
actually we would actually list the side
effects like caffeine's addictive it can
cause Jitters it can uh a lot of
headaches migraines things like that a
few sweating yeah sweating do a lot of
things caffeine's a drug man but
coffee's cool we like coffee
I love coffee they do and the rise of
Roberto Jr breakfast blend is like my
favorite it's really good yeah I'm
excited I'm excited for the K-Cups so we
can just put them in and then we're
doing limited edition uh bags yeah so
there'll be a different picture of
Roberto Junior on each bag but it'll be
a limited run oh whoa and then we're
also thinking of doing just outright
limited edition runs like we might just
do one thousand of one kind with one bag
and that's it never never anymore sweet
yeah so there will be like special ones
yeah we can make we can make like a
Labonte Brew or something you know and
like just like a one run like my face
like big old mouth open on it
ah we'll grab some more where we're at
the average guy reacts as the at the
beginning of your stream was a Bud Light
advertisement yeah amen I'll take their
money I don't care yeah you know it's
like if Bud Light loses money and gives
me money and they want to make their
argument to you that's that's exactly
the point I think they're allowed to
make their case and make their argument
and if it sways you then good good for
them you know yeah I got no issue
because I can come on my show and I can
say what I think about them and that's
that's fine I don't think I don't think
they're convincing anybody but they can
try no apparently it's been happening
all week too so like yeah someone
mentioned Goose Island too yeah yeah
they're trying but this is where they
should advertise yeah right I mean like
people are the people who are watching
here are the ones who are perturbed so
just went back Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Tim you gotta check out the latest cast
Castle the burdening the Crowder bit
with Taylor yelling at Wesley was better
than the actual leaked footage plus
bertman's alien rupture damn I look good
I've heard really really good things and
uh I've heard really good things about
the cinematography they've been they've
been doing a really great job with uh
improving the quality and all that stuff
yeah so you know my attitude with cast
Castle is um there is a structure plan
for it but I'm kind of just
like they're gonna do their thing you
know I don't know and uh
we got to a point where enough people
signed up to be members this is the
funny thing about cast Castle so this is
like our our sitcom kind of joke show
where we make poke fun at stuff and um
for a while we were like it's not really
working we don't know what we're going
to do and it was a vlog and it was like
making some money and then we did this
members only version of it which was
more fiction fictionalized version of
what's going on here in the culture war
and we got enough people to sign up that
actually covers the cost of doing cast
Castle as a show so now I'm just kind of
like okay we did it like that's it would
be great if we got a million views and
it was like this Big Show and everyone
thought it was funny but we're at a
point where enough people like it and
are paying monthly that it covers the
costs of doing the show and I'm like we
could basically run it forever now yeah
so there's no that that's it just there
you go have fun guys and enough people
like it once you cover overhead and like
you know then it's then it's all gravy
you know it's like that's the that's the
goal like people do get worked up in and
thinking of you know what get wrapped up
in where am I successful when can I
consider myself a success I think that a
good metric of it is can you do what you
wanted to do what you love to do and pay
your bills and if you can do that then
you're successful anything after that is
you know that's gravy but if you can
live your life doing what you want to do
that's that's successful in my opinion
Knuckles Bank says that after show last
night was worth every dollar spent on
timcast facts don't care come on man you
know the thing yeah so so I really do
recommend it um basically what happened
was I made a comment on the Sports
Illustrated cover with Kim Petrus so I
said something about the normalization
of certain predilections and this
resulted in our Friday morning guest who
is a trans woman saying I will not
associate with a person who says these
things even if they're scientifically
accurate
so then we just we went on the members
only and I basically broke down
everything that I was saying how I feel
and my point was ultimately that I in no
way disparaged anybody
by referring to uh
these procedures in this way I presented
sex change surgeries in a very neutral
fashion with my personal negative
leaning opinion without being derisive
or targeting an individual and that was
too much for them they got so greatly
offended by it and then Jordan Peterson
chimed in with a picture of Pennywise
the Clown and I said Dr Peterson woke up
this morning and chose violence
so I recommend you guys check out the
Colby Covington members only show yeah
that's a good one uh and then we have
people call in and uh and then for some
reason the rumble stream didn't work
yeah Rumble book apparently for the
first few minutes yeah they're apart
from what Andrew uh told me later they
were working on some server stuff so it
happens though I'm not worried about we
we just restarted and we were gonna go
and the app I think is almost ready to
go here's the problem getting the app on
timcast App on apple is crazy hard yeah
on Google apparently it's super easy
yeah Play Store yep that Apple Store
all right we'll grab some more Super
chants meme TV says Kingsley thank you
for standing up and continuing to
support Trump we appreciate you ah
you're welcome yes I am a big Trump
supporter 24 have not left the Trump
train uh I think he's the only one that
can take down the entrenched Elite Class
that controls all of our institutions as
I was saying earlier in Washington DC
inside the Beltway the people that hate
those of us who live outside the Beltway
and hate our values um so I'm behind him
100 right on him Adam says hey Tim can
you give a shout out to the new movie
sound of Freedom starring Jim Caviezel
comes out July 4th thanks that has been
in the works for like a super long time
they had a really hard time finding
distribution for that film there's like
a lot of what's it about in that it's
about human trafficking
um it was like the first thing Jim
Caviezel did after he got after he
finished Person of Interest he did a
couple of
um audio books and stuff
um related to religious you know to his
religious convictions and stuff like
that but this is his first I think
full-length film in that period of time
and I'm very excited to see that movie
boosted Yogi says would you consider
having Jared McNeil on he's a freestyle
Motocross rider that has lived in the
states for 13 years married and has a
child was recently denied his green card
because he doesn't have the jab
absolutely uh that sounds like a good
culture War episode yeah should
definitely have a month
Wyatt kaldenberg says I noticed that on
most local elections in my small City
there are many offices that no one runs
for in these cases City Hall appoints
people how do we fill these battles to
the right people uh that's you yeah Ron
yeah there you go figure out where no
one's running take the job yep there you
go that's what you were talking about
earlier I feel like taking like matters
into your own hands yep doing the work
yeah too many of us are sitting on the
sidelines we've got to get in the fight
right I asked perplexity.ai
if it was considered homosexual if a
male was engaging in activities with a
trans woman and it said there's no clear
consensus and then actually goes into
great detail explaining the positions of
the left and the right on it and I
thought it was really interesting so
then I asked it would it be considered
homosexual if two trans women were
engaged in activities with each other
and it said it there's no clear there's
no way to know and I'm like that kind of
feels like even the left would agree is
you know like two Trans Am it's two
women then clearly it would be
considered homosexual right
but you know the AI is like low man I I
got no idea
it's too scary getting canceled I just
want to get involved you know yeah
barfind says why does this guy remind me
of Keanu Reeves
who which guy was that was from one of
the stories not sure which guy that was
8 30 I don't know trash Panda says yep
we are the ones trying to be healthy I'm
currently at the gym getting in a full
body workout deadlifts for the god
Emperor good and and tomorrow morning
we're all going on a big family uh skate
trip we're gonna have a picnic because
we're gonna get good food then we're
gonna exercise all day get real sweaty
and do some flippy flops and whirly
birds and in the case of Brett he's
gonna do some grindy lose yes
some spinnerifics
Andres he says Tim your future scenario
is a roundabout secular realization of
the Book of Revelation ha ha ha
uh secular realization
my future scenario which one is that the
conservative future
roundabout secularism because I'm not an
atheist
what is that what is what is it's
secular is that a reference to what
secular means not like not having an
actual religion I suppose that's that's
correct but I do believe in God yes I
have some form of religion yeah like I
consider myself agnostic so I don't know
because like anything about like Spirit
realm or whatever is outside of humans
ability to know you can't you can only
know the things that happen inside of
our reality anything else is a matter of
Faith so I don't know and so because I
don't know I can't say there is or is
not
hmm
this is my take on it yeah it yeah
Let's uh we'll grab some more
Matt nail says Tim you are talking about
the right conservative surviving if
there's a famine apocalypse Angel
Studios the makers of the chosen series
is doing a campaign make a show called
Homestead it's about exactly that
I mean I'm watching that show Sweet
Tooth have you guys seen it no no the
the the world economic Forum propaganda
oh oh that's what I think Alex Jones
said about it and I'm watching it and
it's like
do you know what really really just
the there's two things in in pop culture
I cannot stand watching the first is any
fictional show any any depiction really
of a dog being hurt like I don't I don't
care if it's like a fake TV show if it's
a real thing like on the news I'll be
angry like the cops going to the house
and they shoot a dog but if it's like
I'm watching a movie and the bad guy
like kills a dog that's why that's why I
like John Wick I was like I'm going to
see that movie because like he gets
revenge over it like everybody knows you
know kill the dog right yeah and the
other thing is when there's a poke post
uh post-apocalyptic world and
a character destroys the last chance of
the last remnants of humanity I'm like
that is on par with killing a dog in
fiction for me so
like Horizon Zero The Horizon series the
video games
I view the main character so the new
game came out a few months ago the new
expansion just came out it's about a
post-apocalyptic world I she's the bad
guy you play the bad guy
I'm sorry like I don't want to spoil too
much because the game did just come out
and people are probably still playing it
but I view her as the bad guy just like
maliciously evil Eric it's it's like
leftist ideological evil the old world
must be destroyed by any means necessary
just like oh evil and then um I'm
watching Sweet Tooth and I don't want to
spoil this too because I think season
two just came out but same thing man
like the good guys are the people in
these series who are like let's Wipe Out
All Humans success and development it is
very Ishmael it is very like go back to
living in the caves yeah no way man
return to Monkey but in a bad way but in
a bad way return to monkey is is a
terrible idea it is it is
return to return to tradition is
different but yeah monkey is the is like
the making fun of that even return to
tradition like there are people that
take it a little too far the Deus Vault
people yeah yeah yeah
I like the I like indoor plumbing and I
like you know the modern
the modern world I like air conditioning
you know I like the modern world that we
live in and big part of my problem with
the commies is the Eco commies that want
to say you can't have air conditioning I
will use fuel for your car I will say
this so the first horizon game which
came out several years ago I don't mind
spoiling because it's set it's like
super old at this point but basically
the world ends because automated
machines are self-replicating to the
point where they're destroying the
ecosystem Humanity has 16 months left to
live they build underground terraforming
Labs so that after all of life is wiped
out they can Brute Force the machines
shut them down and then re-terriform the
Earth and clone humans to repopulate it
and then the industrialists who made the
robots decides to purge the Apollo
program which is the program that would
have educated the new humans so instead
they grow up in complete ignorance
literally knowing nothing but English
and then the whole world becomes like
just a bunch of really dumb
superstitious people killing each other
either
brutal slavery and the guy says like
they won't repeat the same mistake so
I'll erase all of the knowledge of
humanity and I'm like that that's that's
the bad guy yeah and so I'll just put it
simply without spoiling the other game
you basically become the bad guy and I'm
just like well if how come here's what I
think in the first game they recognized
destroying all of human knowledge was
evil in the second game they are now
leftists who are like actually that was
the good thing and I'm just like
not not a fan I don't like it
knee Boop says get the chick to talk
just like yesterday let the guest talk
I'm thinking I think people need to
understand like
people talk if they can talk
I I'll I'll point out this out too like
there are episodes where you may notice
there will be a silence yeah it is rare
but there will be a silence if nobody
talks
there's nothing you can do and it goes
on forever in your brain when you hear
it like when you're here and you see
there is the moment we're at lulls it
just it lasts for an eternity in a
second yo I'll get people being like why
isn't Someone So speaking why isn't the
guest speaking why isn't this person
speaking and then I'll be like okay
let's let's let's let's let some air
rest and then no one talks yeah and it's
like okay anywhere where were we yeah
people can only talk if they want to
talk you know or if they have something
to say you know if you know anything to
say like
it's probably better to not say anything
if you don't have anything to say right
yesterday in gaming says Tim you're
forgetting about the lab-grown babies
that can be raised by AI they don't need
families all they need to do is realize
they're having a population crisis and
use technology to replace the family
unit
that's enough internet for today
I don't I don't I don't think so I mean
that is like at the end of the first
horizon game you go into one of the
ectogenic ectogenic machines and then
you can see old holographic recordings
and it's like children were born but had
no education and the machines were just
like time for food children and then if
the kids tried to go into the classroom
where the program had been purged it
beats them like wow yeah it was like
like that room is off limits children
and they're like we want to know what's
in there and they're like no and then it
shows them on the ground writhing in
pain that's like the Nikola Tesla like
man-made Horrors Beyond Comprehension
like I just don't even want to live in
that world yeah that if I die before
then like I just don't want to deal with
it that is my biggest fear about Ai and
also brain implants and and being able
to produce in like worlds in your
Virtual Worlds inside your head or
whatever I think that people are gonna
really do disgusting disgusting
disgusting things bro haven't you seen
Black Mirror yeah
the dude in the fighting game you know
that one no have you guys you haven't
seen this one there's a there's a
virtual reality game where you put this
thing on your temple and then it
transports you into the game and so it's
a fighting game and these two guys it's
two adult black men who are friends are
playing the game and one guy chooses the
Asian fighter guy and the other guy
chooses the female fighter and then they
end up banging all like non-stop in the
game and I'm like I'm watching it I'm
like why does the game allow that like
someone programmed the ability to like
do it in this game because why would
anyone play the fighting game if they
just made a sex game and then like so
these two guys are in a relationship in
the game but out of the game they're
like weirded out by each other and then
the one guy's like I can't do this I'm
like I'm I'm married you know I can't
keep doing this and then
the other guy who's like an adult black
man who goes into the video game and
keeps playing the same like Asian female
character says he like banged a panda
bear and like just did all the freaky
things in the world and then the two
guys meet up they both kiss each other
and they're like that was awful and
they're like okay we should never do
that again but then they decide to go
back into the game and keep up the
relationship and their wives let them do
it
what like black I I like Black Mirror I
think it's gross but I think it's
interesting how Black Mirror explores
what people will do given this
technology all you have to do is watch a
pride parade and you then can
extrapolate what types of deviant
Behavior people will do and if you want
to do stuff that like what you want to
do in your life is your own business but
constantly like inundating your brain
with dopamine it's it is not good for
your brain it's not good for your brain
at all you know there's a
I shouldn't say too much right now but
there's a big event coming up next month
and I'm wondering if maybe we do like a
members only party at the new timcast
space
yeah we'll have to figure it out because
um
one of the issues we're having is that
in order for the second and third floor
to be open to the public as a public
accommodation it has to be handicap
accessible oh yeah
which is crazy for a building built in
1902 fortunately the dude who built it
back in the day put an elevator in it
the only problem is it's an elevator
from 1902. yeah so that means we have to
it we're allowed to use it for private
purposes but if we open the doors as a
public accommodation we can't use that
elevator it's too old you have to put a
new one in there yeah and it's it's
actually not that difficult they're like
uh it's I think it's like twenty
thousand dollars to thirty thousand
dollars that's not bad it's a lot of
money for like for a building
modification it's actually not that
crazy but for like me to have to that
that's kind of crazy but uh if we do it
private if it's a private establishment
it's not open to the public then we
don't and we're fine you can go up the
stairs and then anybody who's either
like in a wheelchair or crutch or
something they just use the elevator it
works but for the public we can't do it
but maybe we do something and um I'll
I'll leave it at that but I would I'll
just say I think it would cause a big
Ruckus if I if we did it would because
of what next month is
yeah next month is rainbow like company
logo month basically monkeypox is gonna
go through the roof
no no but they put a warning button they
did yeah
they just said summer Gatherings they
didn't say what kind of gatherings are
contributing to the case rise
if if we did an event a members only
thing timcast.com members would get
an email saying like hey here's what the
party's going to be only a certain
amount of tickets are available please
RSVP
we would we would basically
own that town for that weekend yeah you
know we could do something really cool
maybe we should reach out maybe like a
permit for a block party or something
that'd be sick then we could have like
All That Remains play
next month that's a short notice
you know but then we just take over I'll
I'll tell you the details and you'll
understand everything in private I don't
want to say too much just yet but uh you
know maybe
Vigilant says I was unsubscribed
yesterday from IRL
what yeah they do that stuff they do
that stuff yeah it's happened to me
before Kenny Loggins says Tim you don't
live in a video game you're pretty much
in the DMV you're not in Montana if it
hits the fan you're just as screwed as
the next guy that is incorrect you're
incorrect sir the person who lives in DC
is very very screwed we are moderately
screwed and the guy in Montana is fine
yeah so we are not the same as the next
guy I I we have
we are well armed in the mountains
surrounded by right-wing nut jobs we are
so well I will say though like what
about like Ruby Ridge that guy was
totally Off the Grid well armed they
still got him but but if we're talking
about a collapse technically they got
his wife and in the head while she was
carrying the baby then and Randy Weaver
like they they paid him for killing his
wife jeez yeah but everybody passed away
I think that's the federal government
they can do that stuff now mm-hmm if the
system collapses and there is no federal
government anymore people in cities are
going to be very hungry and they'll
start spreading out like a wave in every
direction and we are elevated most of
these people are not going to want to
climb uh up the 200 or 300 foot
elevation where we are from the rivers
if they do they're in serious trouble
because one we are well armed and two in
The High Ground I'm not really worried
and we're surrounded by right-wing nut
jobs I think the first thing that
happens is if if if something hit the
fan
we'd have a group of people at the
intersection waving waving down the
column being like which house do you
live in where are you at we're gonna
have a meeting they put up flyers and be
like emergency community meeting and
then we would make determinations on
where the barriers go up who who's going
to be working watch who was our law
enforcement I think we'd be pretty good
every single person is going to be like
here's who I am here's my name here's my
family no no us
you know we'll have a passcode for the
neighborhood everybody's armed we don't
have a lot to worry about and the
Preppers will be so excited because it's
what they've been waiting for this whole
time I don't think they'll be excited at
all I think it'll just be like another
Monday who else who else here at the
castle has night vision besides me and
you Tim
who else has got it dude in the in what
is it after the collapse of the United
States in the middle of uh the mountains
the man with night vision is King you
know no joke no joke especially if
you've got dual tubes then you can walk
through the woods without falling on you
I got those and imagine it's a new moon
it's pitch black outside there's limited
light you by yourself can can take over
properties and and it's just night
vision's no joke I was reading about how
uh U.S military superiority a lot of it
is based on night vision yeah going into
like the Middle East where these people
can't see anything in the dark and they
walk through like it's daytime like man
Night Vision Night Vision dual tubes are
good for like if you have to move around
and then if you're if you're gonna like
just like check out a position get
thermal but thermal's no good for when
you're moving around because you can't
see stuff but thermal you can see if
there's anyone there and the night
vision will go ahead and get you there
cool technology so the NB says Tim your
only net positive taxpayers can vote is
a great idea until something happens
that leads to only the rich World
economic Forum types able to vote bad
idea no
because
they would have to then allocate their
tax money to you
otherwise if they don't you become a net
net taxpayer so it's possible what they
do then is they say
so imagine this way let's say there's
five billionaires and they say all right
we're going to implement a tax on uh at
X percent
let's say only they pay it and they're
all paying one billion dollars so five
billion dollars goes into the tax coffer
that divided amongst all of the people
gives them a couple dollars in tax
liability in in tax benefit meaning if
you then pay five dollars in taxes
you're now a net taxpayer and you get to
vote so it's an interesting idea I don't
know I don't know if it does work but
that is not a reason why it would not it
would have to be like
if there's a hundred million people
paying taxes and 250 who aren't
then those hundred million can vote but
if this 100 million vote to take away to
to lower taxes because they don't want
to pay them that makes more net tax net
taxpayers who can vote so you see
eventually you'll find an equilibrium
yeah being a billionaire won't save you
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com and buy cast of
brew coffee at casper.com you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at timcast Kingsley you want to shout
anything out yeah just please follow me
at Kingsley Cortez on all the platforms
thanks for having me tonight guys
absolutely
I am Phil Labonte the lead singer of All
That Remains you can check me out on
Twitter I'm Phil that remains on
Instagram I am Phil that remains
official uh the band is All That Remains
check us out on Spotify Apple music
Pandora I think uh YouTube you know
all of us guys if you'd like to follow
me you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Brett dasovic on both of
those on both of those platforms and
please check out pop culture crisis
Monday through Friday 3 P.M Eastern
Standard Time that is noon Pacific right
here on YouTube we had a great episode
today gothics was in the studio with us
go check that one out it was great guys
and I am search.com you can follow me on
Twitter you can follow me on Instagram
follow me on Soundcloud too that'd be
kind of cool but uh I'm really close to
a lot more people on Twitter than I ever
thought I would have them like things
like 8 000 so
maybe you could be the 8 000 person and
I'll talk to you for like 10 minutes
maybe I don't know cheers guys right on
well everybody we'll have Clips up
throughout the weekend we do have some
documentaries that are coming out soon
we wanted to put out Lauren and uh we
had Lauren and Ben uh Lauren Southern
and Ben Stewart here because we're like
we're gonna get ready to launch but then
we uh we needed to run them through
basically like copyright check which
ended up taking longer because it always
does and I'm like but uh hopefully those
are out in the next week or so and then
maybe two weeks actually we're also
thinking of doing a full Premiere so
after we were like let's do the legal
check I think uh Lauren and John were
like what would you think about doing a
Premiere I was like I would gladly do it
a theater release that would be
fantastic and like well why don't we do
it I'm like okay well then we need a
month to prepare so maybe we do that but
I kind of just want to release them
we'll see what happens but I do
appreciate all of your support you make
it possible thanks for hanging out
everybody and we will see you back on
Monday